.
Let's begin to solve the issue of descent
Then we can deal with tougher issues. If I have
Ratio 13/6 = 5 / x
I do not prefer having this x in the denominator, so let us
Multiply the two ends of this equation by x
If both sides hit x, what would happen?
On the right side, this x is deleted with that x
Then the left side becomes our 13 / 6x
= - We will get 5 here
Then, until we find the value of x, we have to multiply both ends
Inverted 13/6
Ie 6/13
These are clearly deleted
That's why I hit him in the reverse
We get x = 5 x 6, which equals 30/13
Now the way you go until you finish this issue - it's about
Jump for a step - called cross-strike
Look at the ratio so, and directly say
Rugs in this aspect x placed in that side
= Rugs in this aspect ×
In that aspect
Let me write it down
Maybe sometimes you see people moving directly to - call me
Re-write the current issue - if
The original issue is 13/6 = 5 / x
Maybe you sometimes see people moving directly to
13 x x = 5 x 6
It may seem like a charm
How can he succeed?
Why is it true?
In fact, what is being done to get to this point is
They strike both ends of the equation
Both houses
Let me explain what I mean
If both ends of the equation are multiplied by 6 and x
What will happen?
If both ends of the equation are multiplied by 6x
Where did you get the 6?
from here
Where did you get x?
Of both
What will happen?
On this side of the equation, the 6 will be deleted
With this place
On the right side of the equation, x will be
Delete it with this title
If we have 13 × x
= 5 x 6
There is nothing imaginary here
We hit the two sides
The equation
This seems to be a reciprocal hit
13x = 5 x 6
Then here, of course, we divide both sides on 13
We get x = 30/13
Now that we've solved the warm-up exercise, let's tackle some
Actual issues
We have the highest mount in
Canada is Mount Yukon
It is 298/67 the size of Mount Ben Nevis
Let's put Y ratio for Yukon equal to 298/67 of size - let's say that
N ratio to Nevis
This is what tells us what is written in green
Top Summit in Scotland
Mount Elbert is in Colorado is the highest peak
In the Rocky Mountains
Mount Elbert - if we have this other information here - Mt.
Elbert is 220/67 from the height of Ben Nevis
So let's put E as a shortcut to Elbert
E = 22/67 × Nevis
× Ben Nevis, here
He gave us more information
It is 44/48 of the size of Mount Blanc
If Elbert = 44/48 the size of Blanc
Let's write B relative to Mount Blanc
We also gave Mount Blanc a 4,800 meter height
The height of Mount Blanc equals 4,800
meter
If B = 4,800
What is required of us is, how high is Mount Yukon?
If we have to find Y
So let's do the opposite, and find all
Existing variables
Let's start with this information
B = 4,800
E = 44/48 × B
If E-Elbert - equals 44/48 × Mount Blanc, it is
4,800 m
Now if we divide it by 48-4800 = 48 = 100--
If Elbert's incidence is equal to 44 x 100 meters
Which equals 4,400 meters
that's enough
Now we can use this information and
We make it up here
We get Elbert, whose height is 4,400 meters, =
220/67 × Ben Nevis
N Abbreviation for Nevis
To find Nevis rise, we hit both ends
Inverted this coefficient
If we hit both sides with 67/220
X 67/220
67 Delete with 67
220 Delete with 220
And then we get - let us see, if you take 4,400.
220 - 440 220 220 = 2
If this equals 20
4,400 220 220 = 20
We got the Nevis rise and equal - change sides -
If height Ben Nevis = 67 × 20 meters
Now how much is this?
1,340 m
Is this true?
Well, let's leave him like that, because we can
- In fact it looks like 67 - I'll leave Nevis
So 67 x 20 meters
We make it up here
If Yukon - I will come down here, because I have
Larger space - Yukon = 298/67
Ø Nevis height
Nevis = 67 × 20
If × 67 × 20
Well I can divide 67 on 67, and get Yukon up
298 x 20 meters
If Yukon = 298 × 20
How much is this?
This equals - let us see 2 × 298
= 396
Oh sorry, it's worth 596
It's almost 300, if it should be close to 600
2 less than 300, so must
To be 4 less than 300
And then I have 0 here
If it equals 5,960 meters
We're done
Let's solve another issue. this is good
In a big big high school, he was rated 2 out of every
3 students have a mobile phone
And 1 in 5 of all students have a mobile phone
Its production year ranges from one year or less
this is good
Let's think about it
Let's assume that x = the total number of students
x = total number of students
This first line, 2 out of 3 students have a mobile phone
We can say that 2/3 x have a mobile phone
They have a mobile phone
This is what the sentence written in green says
Then the sentence is written in violet-1 color of 5 out of all
Students have a mobile phone of one year or less
If 1/5 x have less than 1/5 years
.
If we need to know how many students they have
Mobile phone - it's the outside of this - that's the place
Let me write it down
That is the place
Find students who have a mobile phone - this
Here - we need to know what percentage they have
Mobile phone year produced more than a year
So how many students have one year of mobile phone production
From one year?
Well, we can take the total number of students who have a mobile phone
Which is 2/3 x
2/3 of all students have a mobile phone
We can ask all students who have
A new mobile phone - a mobile phone whose production year is less than a year -
Remember that we were told more than a year here
If we want to ask all the students who have
A modern mobile phone, ie 1/5 x, so we will get a percentage
The students who have this
This is here
This has a mobile phone greater than 1/5 years
They have a phone, but the year of production is more than 1/5 years
This is for all who own a mobile phone
We ask the new
So this is all students who have
Mobile phone year was produced before the year of Akbar
To find this, we offer fractions
If this equals, let's see, 2/3 is equivalent
10/15
This is 2/3 - 1/5
Equivalent to 3/15 x
Which equals 10 - 3 = 7/15 x
It's the total proportion of students
Written in orange - what percentage of those who own a phone
The year of its production was before the end of the year?
It's 7/15 x
This is the actual number
If you want to know how many students have a mobile phone
- Number of students who have a mobile phone
Here - 2/3 x, what percentage of those who have a phone year of production was more
From one year?
This is the number of students who have a mobile phone a year earlier
One year
This total value is the proportion of students
Who have a mobile phone
Fortunately, the x is deleted
And we have this = 7/15 x
Upside down
Divide on 2/3
This is equivalent to multiplying by 3/2
How much is this?
Divide on 3
Our remaining 7/10
Of the students who have a mobile phone, here are 7 out of 10
Students who have a mobile phone have a mobile phone that was a year old
More than one year
We're done
.